six dernières questions inscrites à
l'ordre du jour la question 596 de
monsieur philippe bas à madame la garde
des sceaux ministre de la justice
merci monsieur le président
madame la ministre
le parlement a adopté le 5 mars 2007 une
loi nouvelle sur la protection des
incapables majeurs puisque c'est ainsi
qu'il convient de les nommer la
philosophie de cette loi
voulait que on n'enferme pas dans le
statut d' incapables majeurs des
centaines de milliers de nos
compatriotes alors que ce qui a justifié
la mesure de protection peut être un
état temporaire et c'est vrai que
jusqu'à présent les tutelles et
curatelles rester
définitivement applicable aux personnes
pour lesquelles le juge les avait
prononcé le système de la loi de 2007 a
conduit à ce que les mesures de
protection soient
régulièrement remise en question et
réexaminé par le juge et il a fallu
aussi dans cette loi que j'ai eu
l'honneur de défendre au nom du
gouvernement devant le parlement lequel
adopter cette loi sans aucune opposition
les
dispositions qui ont été prises ont dû
aussi traiter le cas des personnes qui à
la date de l'entrée en vigueur de la loi
bénéficier d'une mesure de protection
mais la loi dit il faut que ces
personnes elles aussi voient leur statut
réexaminée au bout d'un certain délai le
premier délai qui a été fixé était
manifestement trop court pour que les
juges puissent
revoir toutes les situations il y a eu
un second délai qui a été décidé par le
parlement qui a reporté de trois ans la
première échéance ce second délai arrive
à expiration au 31 décembre
et nous savons par une enquête des
services judiciaires qui l'y a
actuellement plus de cent mille
personnes bénéficiant d'une mesure de
protection dont la situation n'aura pas
été réexaminée au 31 décembre or le 31
décembre c'est une date couperet et
toutes les personnes dont la situation
n'aura pas été réexaminé verront la
mesure de tutelle qui dans la plupart
des cas leur est toujours nécessaire
tomber et à ce moment là nous entrons
pour ces personnes en grande difficulté
personnelle dans un univers qui est un
univers inconnu et dangereux donc ma
question est de savoir ce que le
gouvernement compte faire pour que cette
date du 31 décembre soit reportée mais
qu'elle le soit dans des conditions qui
permettent de mettre en oeuvre
effectivement le réexamen de toutes les
situations pour permettre à des
personnes qui aurait recouvré leur
faculté de pouvoir échapper aux mesures
de protection les plus fortes qui sont
mises en oeuvre
merci madame la ministre
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre
merci de cette question qui pose un
véritable problème au regard des
tutelles et curatelles comme vous
l'avait indiqué il n'est pas question
bien entendu de remettre en cause le
bien fondé de la loi initial du 5 mars
2007 portant réforme de la protection
juridique des majeurs et le problème que
pouvait poser la nouvelle date limite du
1er janvier 2014 prévue par le
législateur bien entendu devait faire
vous l'avez dit l'objet d'une
réouverture d'un réexamen sous peine de
caducité au regard de l'importance du
volume de dossiers à renouveler puisque
au 1er janvier 2009
629 1078 mesure devait faire l'objet
d'une révision dans les 304 tribunaux
d'instance et quatre tribunaux de
première instance il y avait là un défi
de taille pour les juridictions et au 31
décembre 2012
29,1 pour cent de ces mesures restaient
encore à renouveler voilà des chiffres
qui effectivement montre la gravité de
la situation la garde des sceaux qui m'a
d'ailleurs m'a demandé de l'excusé
auprès de vous monsieur le ministre
cette ce matin a été sensibilisés à ce
problème et aux inquiétudes ressenties
par les juridictions compétentes pour
faire face à cette charge il s'agit
d'une loi d'une portée sociétale
essentiels qui vise à protéger vous
l'avait bien dit les personnes
vulnérables ou substantiellement
vulnérables l'évolution de la situation
a été suivi avec une extrême attention
par le ministère qui a veillé à apporter
les réponses les moyens ont été mis à
disposition des services des tutelles
pour assurer la résorption du stock
affectation de magistrats de greffiers
place et d'assistants de justice de
vacataires des charges des juges
d'instance à l'activité du tribunal de
grande instance en s'appuyant sur ses
moyens ses juges ont fourni un effort
remarquable qu'il faut saluer si bien
qu'une nouvelle mesure de report ne
paraît plus être nécessaire au 30
septembre 2013 ce sont c'est le chiffre
que jolie 48 1875 mesure qui restait à
renouveler et non pas les 100000
monsieur le ministre que vous avez
indiquée les projections au 31 décembre
prochain font apparaître qu'entre 1 et 2
7% des mesures n'auront pas été
renouvelé la direction des services
judiciaires travaille désormais pour
examiner la nature de ces mesures il est
apparu en effet que pour certaines
d'entre elles les services des tutelles
n'était pas en mesure de procéder à leur
révision du fait de l'impossibilité de
convoquer les parties en raison souvent
de l'ancienneté de la mesure ou de
déménagements successifs
on est donc confrontée la à du concret à
la réalité sur le terrain en tout état
de cause l'implication des jus j'ai un
fonctionnaire le travail accompli pour
permettre le renouvellement de ces
mesures vous en avez vu la diminution du
nombre mérite véritablement d'être
souligné et salué par ailleurs les
attentes des juges des tutelles et des
associations qui ont fermenté et lacunes
ou difficultés d'application du la loi
du 5 mars 2007 ont été véritablement
entendu dans ce cadre la ministre de la
justice garde des sceaux projette dans
le cadre de l'avant projet de loi
habilitant le gouvernement à légiférer
par ordonnance en matière de
simplification
du droit et des procédures qui doit être
présenté prochainement en conseil des
ministres la ministre est donc prête à
apporter des modifications de la loi du
5 mars 2007 pour alléger ou supprimer
les contraintes nécessaires et ces
mesures sont de plusieurs ordres le
premier permettre au juge de prononcer
sous certaines conditions des mesures
initiales pour une durée supérieure à
cinq ans
cette mesure permettra d'alléger la
charge de travail des services de
tutelle pour les amener à venir mais
surtout répond à une forte demande des
familles et des associations qui
comprenait parfois mal la nécessité de
révision quinquennale de la mesure
lorsque l'état de santé du majeur
protégé ou son handicap ne permettez pas
d'entrevoir d'évolution
deuxième point modifier les modalités
d'arrêt du budget et de contrôle des
comptes de gestion des mesures de
protection troisième mesure substituer
dans les circonstances prévues à
l'article 86 426 du code civil l'avis
d'un médecin extérieur à l'établissement
d'accueil au certificat médical
circonstancié
prévu à l'article 431 du code civil
quatrième mesure prévoir un nouveau
dispositif d'habilitation au bénéfice de
certains membres de la famille d'un
majeur protégé permettant sous certaines
conditions d'éviter le prononcé d'une
mesure de protection judiciaire l'effort
ponctuelle est et intense qui a été
fourni pour aboutir à la révision de la
quasi-totalité des mesures il ne reste
plus que 1 à 2 3% ainsi que ses réformes
de fond laisse envisager une nette
amélioration des conditions de mise en
oeuvre de cette loi avec ce dispositif
monsieur le ministre même si on apporte
pas une solution à toutes les questions
que vous avez porté il y alla de vraies
voies d'amélioration notamment autant
pour les personnes qui souffrent que
pour leurs accompagnants et ceux qui
sont à leurs côtés
merci monsieur philippe bas
merci madame la ministre de cette
réponse qui me rassure c'est vrai que
depuis la sortie de l'étude des services
judiciaires on a le sentiment en vous
écoutant que les juges et des services
du ministère de la justice ont mis les
bouchées doubles et c'est heureux les
situations résiduelles que vous
mentionnez sont sans doute pour beaucoup
d'entre elles liées à des difficultés
concrètes que vous avez également
rappelé ça n'est pas une raison
d'ailleurs pour ne pas rechercher un
traitement individuel de chacune de ces
situations puisqu'il y aura des cas qui
resteront des cas extrêmement sensibles
où la mesure pourrait tomber alors que
son bénéficiaire en or est toujours
besoin vous mentionner aussi un certain
nombre de dispositions que le garde des
sceaux a l'intention de proposer pour
simplifier les procédures en cours je ne
suis pas hostile
je tiens simplement à ce qu'on ne
remette pas en cause le principe d'une
révision régulière à tout le moins pour
celles des situations qui
serait évolutive je conçois bien que
dans le cas de la maladie d'alzheimer ou
d'autres affections mentales on ne
puisse espérer d'améliorations et qu'à
ce moment
les
réexamen régulier les renouvellements de
mesures
régulier ne s'impose pas de la même
manière que pour une personne qui a subi
un accident de la vie et dont on peut
espérer qu'il recouvrera
ses capacités il faut simplement que si
l'on prend ce type de disposition le
fasse de telle manière qu'on aboutisse
pas au résultat que des améliorations de
la situation de la personne ne soit pas
prise en compte et nous serons bien sûr
extrêmement vigilants sur les
caractéristiques techniques et
juridiques des dispositions sur
lesquelles le garde des sceaux travail
merci monsieur philippe bas madame la
ministre merci d'avoir passé une grande
partie de la matinée avec nous vous
l'avez fait avec le brio et l'
enthousiasme qui vous caractérisent mes
chers collègues je vais donc suspendre
la séance elle sera reprise à 14h30 pour
la suite du projet de loi garantissant
la vous